it was a bitter contest but in the end
the favorite came out on top liz truss
has been elected leader of britain's
conservative party and will become the
next uk prime minister the announcement
follows two months of intense
campaigning sparked by the resignation
of prime minister boris johnson trust
who's currently the uk's foreign
minister defeated her rival rishi sunak
she'll follow margaret thatcher and
teresa may to become britain's third
female premier
trust called on her party to rally
around her to fight the many crises
plaguing the country
it's an honor to be elected
as leader of the conservative and
unionist party during this leadership
campaign
i campaigned as a conservative
and i will govern as a conservative
and my friends we need to show that we
will deliver
over the next two years
so she's not even in the post and
already seemingly running out of time
the most pressing issue facing her is
the rising cost of living in the united
kingdom energy prices and shopping bills
are getting more and more expensive many
families are expected to struggle to
make ends meet this coming winter trusts
will also have to settle a series of
industrial disputes and tackle foreign
policy challenges that include the war
in ukraine and last but not least
implementing brexit
there's not a lot of choice when fiona
is making sandwiches for children but
she has to be really careful when buying
food
the cost of living has gone up and
everything is so expensive
like the bread the meal has gone up at
least by 30
it's hard when you've got a family of
four but it's not only food prices a
bigger concern for her are energy builds
i will not be using my gas cocoa in the
winter
um just to the fact that my gas is going
to be
a lot more expensive this year and i'm
not sure if i'll be able to afford it
it'll just be easy food that doesn't
take up too much gas and electric
but how to keep the children warm once
colder weather comes is worrying her
even more
you have to wrap up in the house
wear extra clothing in the winter
instead of putting on the heating i do
try and work full time but i still i
still seem to struggle
life for fiona is a fight but she fears
this coming winter things might be
getting even harder for her and the
children
at this central london hospital another
shift is getting underway for the
ambulance crews every day they're
bringing in more patients than the
emergency room can handle we're just
struggling to even get people into the
doors of the a e and we're having to
treat them in the back of the ambulance
and some of these time critical
illnesses like strokes and heart attacks
are just simply not being seen in time
this leads to waging ambulances stacking
up outside the hospital doors in the end
endangering people's lives
because of these delays at hospital we
are sitting here unable to answer the
999 calls that are coming in i've
personally witnessed deaths where we
have been to someone who might have
called for chest pain
and 12 15 hours later we've turned up to
the house and this person is deceased
understaffed underfunded and close to
breaking down these professionals are
dealing with the crisis of the national
health service on a daily basis we're in
the middle of the biggest staffing
crisis the nhs has ever seen in its
history on top of that this government
has no credible plan to actually fix
these problems aaron himself is doubtful
whether he'll be able to carry on in the
job for much longer
a day out on the beach for many
londoners this means a trip to brighton
but swimmers should think again on rainy
days raw sewage is being pumped out of
this drainage pipe straight into the sea
this is victorian technology this is 150
years old what we're experiencing in
this country is a lack of investment in
our infrastructure which means these are
being used on a constant regular basis
this happens across the country
for years now he and his fellow
activists have been fighting against the
water companies responsible for this
practice so far without success you're
surfing with all of the things that come
out of people's toilets you know you've
got sanitary towels you've got the paper
and everything else that goes in with it
and also you know a feces as well
raw sewage on britain's speeches
this is a nation that has more than one
crisis on its hands
looks like liz trust has got her work
cut out for her and to walk us through
how she might go about tackling all
these simultaneous crises i'm pleased to
bring in katherine bernard she's a
professor of eu law and employment law
at trinity college at cambridge
university she's also a deputy director
of the think tank uk in a changing
europe ms bernard thank you so much for
taking the time to be on the day tonight
with us
liz trusts is often compared to margaret
thatcher she personally says she doesn't
like that comparison and that she's very
much her own person so what kind of a
prime minister is she going to be
well uh she may say now that she doesn't
like to be compared with margaret
thatcher but she's gone to a lot of
trouble to try to mimic or echo margaret
thatcher and it's been very odd
throughout the entire contest to have
two
pretenders for the prime minister's
throne and they both harped back to
margaret thatcher who was prime minister
30 years ago they all want to wear the
mantle of margaret thatcher
and she certainly will follow margaret
thatcher's shoes of
she wants to be small state tax cutting
conservative but as your report has just
shown the fact is that the state needs
to have a huge amount of money pumped
into it and yet liz trust has promised
tax cuts and this is why uh there's a
lot of concern on the markets about how
she's actually going to deliver on the
promise of cutting taxes while also
fixing for example the national health
let's talk about how you think she will
go about delivering to the british
people she
really emphasized that she was going to
deliver deliver the liver in her
acceptance speech any idea how she plans
to do that
well
it's all very well saying deliver
delivered deliver but in fact
she's given very very little away about
how she's actually going to do this
at the start of her campaign she said
she was going to give no handouts she
was going to focus on tax cuts
but of course as the reality of the
energy crisis looms she's now talking
about doing something about the energy
crisis but she won't tell us what she's
going to do
now it's quite clear that civil servants
have been working on a package of
measures that they can present to her
once she becomes prime minister and she
promises that the nation will be told
what she's going to do by the end of the
week but of course that's only one part
of the package because she still wants
to do tax cuts the only way this can be
delivered is by massive government
borrowing and the levels of government
borrowing could be really substantial
possibly
just to pay for the uh
energy crisis 100 billion and if you
think about that in order to pay for the
furlough scheme during the pandemic that
cost the country 70 billion and so what
she needs to spend to try and assist
people with energy crisis is 30 billion
more than was spent on the furlough
scheme
how does the british public feel about
her because she was voted into the post
by some 80 000 members of her own party
how does the general public feel about
her and her fairly vague approach to all
these crises
yeah the general public is not that warm
about her they think she is somewhat out
of touch
and they really don't have much
confidence in her ability to deliver
indeed looking at the figures 12 percent
of britons think she'll be a great or
good prime minister but 52 um descent of
britain's um in a yougov survey thought
she would be terrible or at least poor
and so there's not a lot of faith in her
and the very fact that she is
seen as the heir to boris johnson uh
good thing for party members who's many
of whom think boris johnson should never
have resigned in the first place but not
so good for the country because the
country clearly is rather suspicious of
boris johnson and his behavior while he
was in office
something people are suspicious about as
well is whether or not she will have
what it takes to implement brexit she
voted for maine in 2016. so what kind of
challenges await her there you think
so many but first and foremost um is
what to do about northern ireland if you
remember the northern ireland protocol
was agreed between
boris johnson and
the eu and the effect of the northern
ireland protocol was to have a border
down the irish sea essentially
separating northern ireland from the
rest of great britain and the
conservatives are now saying this is
totally unacceptable liz truss is um
being a front-runner to say this is
totally unacceptable and she has been
pushing the so-called northern ireland
protocol bill through parliament it's
gone through the commons the lower house
and it's due to go to the lords the
upper house
at the end of october and this bill
essentially rips up the northern ireland
protocol
which is an international treaty uh
which was agreed with the eu in good
faith two years ago
and so she is putting the country on a
collision course with the eu because the
eu cannot
accept that the uk unilaterally breaks
its commitments under an international
treaty with the eu